good evening everybody let's make a
start shall we we'll start by welcoming
you all to tonight's meeting of planning
committee A to B echoing a bit away from
me my name is Danny Kendall I'll be
chairing tonight's meeting accordance
with the rules and procedures are set
out in the front page of your agendas
but if you notices for people before we
get going
mobile phones I can remind members of
public after indeed with members of the
committee to check the mobile phones
have been set to silent very fantastic
and also to let members of the public
know that the meeting is being recorded
tonight as well so that it can be put
onto our website via YouTube in the next
day after so if you want to watch this
back you should feel welcome to do so
right before I move on to meeting
properly I just like to say a few words
and to mark the passing of a member of
this committee actually accounts the
Barnes died a few weeks couple weeks ago
he was a good friend of mine he was a
unique character and I think I don't
think I don't even think that does it
justice actually he was just somebody
who you could never possibly forget one
she'd met him he was a wonderful
wonderful bloke not a huge amount of
time for him since well since joining
the council nearly a decade ago now he
was one of the guys who would always
come up to me and say let me explain
this to you let me explain that do you
give me a few ideas about also today he
was just brilliant so I for one would
miss him and send my thoughts to his
family had this difficult time council
Perry mr. chairman if I could just
record my thanks to Peter Barnes he from
from the day I actually joined the
council Peter took me under his wing and
much that I've learned on the planning
committee has been through
counselor bonds so it's not only it was
a great shock and great sadness and we
also of course have the benefit of his
little dog Max who used to come and sit
over there and he he really did help us
all in making the right decisions I
think but he he he was one of a million
really a real character and for any
counselor who has served as an elected
councillor for 30 years he's somebody
that's really special and I know we'll
all miss him thank you
right so we start tonight's anything if
I can actually put the top table please
to introduce themselves thank you hon
bones from committee services Ross
chambers legal services good evening my
name is David Jeffrey I'm the planning
manager for tonight's meeting my role is
to provide impartial advice to clarify
any planning issues their eyes and to
assist members decision taking in doing
so I'm bound by the Royal Town Planning
Institute's code of Professional Conduct
planning committee members are not bound
by advice from officers or by their
recommendations Sara McPherson planning
officer Steve lighting planning officer
it's on some planet right excellent
so the introductions out the way we
moved to apologies for absence please
disclosure of interests counts Lipari
Thank You chair I wish to disclose an
interest in application number 19
forward slash theory - 9 - 4 /f ul 16
Grange Road
I am the county councillor for barely
and I have been involved in various
discussions with Warwickshire County
Council over a strip of land and have
been party to being copied in on various
emails I think it is most appropriate
that I sit down from the Committee on
this particular application there any
other declarations of interest excellent
right
we moved to item 3 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 18th
of December and you are happy that I
signed those as a record of the meeting
at the end right to move to our first
application tonight then so this
application sorry I - number 4 plan on
page seven of your agendas this
application reference 19 slash is zero
two three nine five slash ful is for the
potting shed compound the hill work Road
stratford-on-avon
and it's for the demolition of all
existing buildings on the site except
the Coach House the construction of
three bungalows and two houses the
conversion of the coach house into a
dwelling the creation of gardens parking
circulation areas minor alterations to
access drive and all other associated
works sending officer Sarah Macpherson
okay thank you Jeff the application site
is the potting shed on welcome road
identified here by the red line as you
can see the site lies too
outside the residential area of
Stratford town and the pink line
indicates the conservation area which
the site entrance is just within the
green dots indicate TPO trees the site
is identified here by black dot the
application is for the demolition of all
buildings at the potting shed shown here
within the Red Line boundary so for the
coach-house which will be converted and
for the erection of five new dwellings
and associated landscaping and
infrastructure here are some photographs
of the site as it presently stands as
you can see several buildings are
derelict as the site has been out back
to be used for some time the photograph
in the top right-hand corner shows the
coach-house building which is to be
restored as part of this application
here is an aerial image showing the
extent of the site here is the proposed
site layouts which you can see broadly
mirrors the layout of the existing built
form the next few slides show the
Barrett's house types the three
dwellings at the top of the site will be
single-story as you see here here and
here these railings reflect a modern
rural style to reflect the existing
chicken shed building the dwellings at
the bottom of the site reflect the
styling of the coach house and here is
the coach house which is to be restored
as you've seen in the report the
application is considered to be in
accordance with the development plan
including the neighbourhood plan and
there are a couple of updates on the
update sheet and the recommendation is
to grant subject to your section 106
agreement
Thank You Sara right first speaker is
the town council council in fragile e
please welcome councillor hi
so you know the routine now three
minutes if you'd remain seated for any
questions I went I won't take three
minutes over to you them the Stratford
neighbourhood plan has agreed by the
planning inspector the residents of the
town adopted by SDC in December 2018
states in policy age 1 the Stratford has
a built-up area boundary and proposals
for new housing within the area
supported in principle further in
poverty h1 estates that all have all
areas beyond the built-up area of the
town up to the outer boundary the
classified as countryside where new
housing is strictly controlled and
limited to dwellings for rural workers
those satisfying rural exception sites
as per annex 2 of the NPP f and those
considered to be of exceptional design
this particular proposal for Newmarket
dwellings for development is in the
towns countryside as defined in the
neighbourhood plan and so Stratford Town
Council does not think that it fits any
of the reasons given for allowing such a
development in the countryside and asked
for the application to be refused
Thank You counsel
any questions from the committee for the
Town Council no in that case council
tragedy thank you very much for your
time tonight and we moved to next
speaker Liz Nicholson please agent to
the
welcome I think he wants another routine
as well don't you sir it's looking
minutes over to you them thank you the
real estate it's been owned by the trust
since 1968 and the existing house the
hill which is next to the potty shaped
compound was converted into five
apartments in the 1980s the potting shed
compound was used for many years as a
main base for both the maintenance and
gardening teams for the trust
there were offices workshops for making
and repairing items there was a sawmill
open storage of materials the walled
garden there were nursery beds
greenhouses a vehicle compound and the
large former chicken shed that you've
seen at the top of the site which was
used for storing larger items on behalf
of the trust all these uses other than
the storage of ceased as the operational
requirements for the trust have changed
over the years
these uses were very specific to the
trust and they were able to successfully
use the site despite the restricted
access and limited nature of the
commercial buildings realistically no
other commercial user is going to be
interested in the site with the
condition and type of buildings the
access the protected trees and the
proximity of residential properties we
believe that the scheme proposed is a
sensitive response to the nature of the
site the layouts height and appearance
of the buildings have resulted from
consideration of the land levels falling
across the site as well as the layout of
the existing buildings with the advice
of an agriculturist the layout protects
the great majority of the trees whilst
also providing gardens largely free from
shading the retention and conversion of
the existing coach house not only finds
a new use for an old building it also
protects four species of bats using the
roof space the relatively low density of
the scheme reflects the character of the
surrounding area some of which lies
within Stratford's Conservation Area
affordable housing public open space and
sill will all be paid to the council as
required before submitting the
application we presented the scheme to a
town council meeting and we held an open
if
for local residents we recognize that
the town council has concerns regarding
the proposals however as the officers
have pointed out in their report this
scheme accords with Greenbelt policy and
it accords with policies H 1 and H 4 the
neighbourhood plan the officers also
recognize that the site is unattractive
and redevelopment for housing is
considered to enhance the character and
appearance of the site
the only realistic purpose of future for
the Society's redevelopment for
residential purposes the overwhelming
feedback from local residents was for a
small number of residential properties
on the site they did not want a
commercial user coming in and they did
not want a high-volume house builder
producing a scheme we believe that
current proposals meet or exceed all
local and national planning policy
requirements and would meet the wishes
of local residents perfect timing thank
you any questions please from the
committee okay thank you my ward member
I don't see him anywhere in the audience
so I'm guessing he's not here tonight
sir points of clarification from the
committee have any questions that was
easy
should we open to go to the debate does
anybody have any thoughts they'd like to
share
capsule richardson accounts with harry
thank you chaired from the town councils
mic their sole objection is this is
outside the built-up area boundary it
strikes me that the built-up area
boundary presumably is along that road
clearly this area has been built on
before so I'm surprised it's not
polluted included in the built-up area
boundary anyway perhaps an oversight row
in that process the case officers were
very clearly explained her reasoning as
to why she feels that this fits with
policy h1 of the strategy and they
development plan on page nine for those
of you looking at the report and that
being the inclusion exception where
appropriate development of brownfield
land beyond the built-up area boundary
is acceptable given that I can see
absolutely no reason why we would not go
with the officers recommendation and so
with that I would propose that we do
just that
thank you Richard Castle Perry Thank You
chair and I'm also in support of this
application particularly as it accords
with a us 10:00 on under the residential
point D which is conversion to a
residential use of a redundant or
disused buildings which fits that so I'm
very happy to second councillor Richards
proposal Thank You Council Perry to have
anybody else wanted to speak in this
debate okay one thing you've just said
basically what I was thinking really we
should take account of the updates in
the sheet our correction of
clarification condition 12 and condition
15 for the true protection there I
presume you both happy with that thank
you been proposed and seconded that we
grant all those in favor could we please
show you know miss Chen thank you the
committee therefore results to grant
application reference 19 slash zero two
three nine five slash ful
so item five some page 19 of your
agendas wait for the clearing yeah okay
so page 19 item five application
reference 19 slash zero to nine to four
slash ful that is a 16 Grange Road
barely and it's for the development of
two three-bedroom houses presenting
offsets Gulati sure after you
Thank You chairman good evening
this application site is within the
village of Bailey as if it's rated both
black dots on the slide here we see a
satellite view of the application site
itself one can see the site is nestled
very much in a draft thought very
boundary of barely the site is also
within the West Midlands
greenbelts and it's within a designated
art and special landscape area here we
have an existing site plan of the size
of its current guys here we now see the
proposed site layout plan detailing the
proposed to dwellings here next to the
host principal dwelling animus 16 which
is here here we have the proposed
elevations with the principal front
elevation here we now have the proposed
indicative street scene plan showing how
the site would sit amongst the existing
housing stock and the missed 16 is here
then we have a vehicle access Drive here
and then more residential properties
there we now have some photos of the
site in its surroundings
this is number here we are still a
public highway looking eastwards this is
number 16 here we then see the
application the site and you cannot see
the curvature of the road going around
on Billy Grange Road we are now looking
in front of number 16 itself looking
southwards and here is the applications
slope itself where you can also see a
small smattering of children's play area
behind officers are aware of a massive
land ownership that has been raised by
the parish council however having raised
its concern with the applicant at the
earliest opportunity they are satisfied
that they have completed the correct
forms and I think it's been completed
correctly officers are happy to proceed
on this basis or assessing the planning
merits of this planning application the
creation of two additional family
dwellings adhering is considered an
acceptable this highly sustainable
location and it here see strategic
objectives of the development plan the
proposed design is considered
commensurate and harmonizes with a
surrounding built for water leading to a
betterment of the existing site and an
enhancement of the existing appearance
Thank You chairman the recommendation is
grant
the reason sits out on pages 20 for your
agenda thank you
thank you sir thank you speaker Kent yes
councillor Richard Leopard my plan it
correctly LePage partly apologies take a
seat please
so you have three minutes if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end and I'll give you a warning the last
ten seconds that's okay okay over to you
good evening councillors Billy parish
council has two points to make an
Adventist application on which we have
taken advice firstly whilst land
ownership is not necessary in obtaining
planning permission the District Council
is obliged to investigate the accuracy
of ownership certificate supplied by
applicants
where there is evidence of an error the
Parish Council has supplied both the
applicant and the District Council with
evidence which clearly shows a portion
of land within the redline which is not
owned by the applicant the evidence
includes the land registry plan the
original 1959 building plans for the
site and both photographic and physical
evidence in this instance certificate a
has been incorrectly signed because
there is clear evidence to suggest that
the applicant does not own all of the
land within the application site failure
to correctly identify owners and
complete the correct ownership
certificate could result in any
subsequent Planning Commission being
caught by the courts in the event of
judicial review consequently the
application is currently invalid and to
approve this application this evening
would be ultra virus and challengeable
in the court my second point the Parish
Council strongly opposes this
application on the grounds of over
development of the site and as a
consequence of this the negative and
harmful effect to dwellings would have
on the character and appearance of the
area the committee report fails to
properly address this key material
planning consideration and therefore the
balanced recommendation is fundamentally
flawed and misleading to new dwellings
on this site together with the host
dwelling represents the density of 50
dwellings per hectare which is not
reflective of the character of the local
area which is built at between 20 25 and
30 dwellings per hectare which was the
recommended maximum at the time that
this estate was built the two dwellings
have been shoehorned into the site
resulting in a cramped form of
development as a result the site
frontage resembles a car park with no
amenity space no room to access the
front door and the host property and
little room to access the rear gardens
this represents defective and
substandard design
consequently the development would fail
to preserve or enhance the character of
the area the parish council would not
oppose the erection of a modest single
dwelling on a site with appropriate
states facing between buildings amenity
space and car parking arrangements the
Parish Council respectfully request that
this application is infused on the
grounds that it is contrary to policy CS
minor de s10 in the core strategy and
corresponding policies and the
submission neighborhood plan
alternatively at the very least the
application should be deferred with a
strong message and acetylenes applicant
that scheme be amended and reduced to a
single modest darling thank you for
listening
Thank You councillor any questions from
the parrot from the committee for the
parish council I think you have one and
I'm not gonna stray into the area of
hypotheticals but you you say that the
current application force harms the or
does not preserve the openness of
Greenbelt area yet you say you think the
parish counts will be happening happy
with one dwelling he has only one
wouldn't harm the openness it would harm
the openness but not to such an extent I
think it can be refused or purely on the
grounds that that harms the openness of
the green it's just one of the points
because two houses are there it's a
total blockage one house would be would
get some room either side okay Thank You
councillor Adam just briefly in relation
to the issue of ownership you know who
if not all owned by the applicant who
the other owner of the land is Miss
Billie parish council
it was very first council we bought the
land or Forex can be canceled in 2014 as
in people's cats origins you able to
indicate on that map or on this drawing
where you think yeah please you just
described it along with in the record is
it the Stewart could just indicate here
that
yes if you look at the red border there
down at the bottom right hand corner
there's a diagonal piece across the red
line at the moment it's where the
applicant believes that the boundaries
but the the diagonal line just to the
left of that is the land belongs to us
understood thank you it's a small piece
of land just confirmed you agree with
the piece that's being indicated at the
moment that's the piece we're talking
about yes thank you right if no other
questions that case counsel thank you
very much for your time move to our next
speaker mr. Richard Ludlow please and
miss Wilcox is he joining you or no okay
thank you welcome so you've got three
minutes if you don't remain see
different questions at the end over to
you
the question that's been raised by the
parish council regarding ownership of
the land
I should explain I'm previously was a
practicing solicitor I no longer hold a
practicing certificate simply because
I've retired but I'm quite satisfied
that's the application which I have
submitted
is it correct if and I do own all of the
land I have little to add to what the
planning officers already said but we've
made every effort to design houses that
fit within the street scene and that are
within the context of Baileys a village
I hope on that basis that the
application could be supported thank you
thank you do have any questions for the
applicant in that case thank you very
much free time as well Thank You
councillor Shelton we don't have think
so okay sports clarification I'll start
with cap switches then I move along
count six after that maybe I'm gonna
start with you
thing I really want to clarify his land
ownership thing you have you been
provided with the evidence to suggests
what is owned by whom have you seen it
and are you you're to say within here
you're satisfied we've been provided
with contradictory statements and
evidence from both parties for our
points of view and the advice we've had
from solicitors is that that's a civil
matter the purpose of the Planning
Department is not to determine who owns
what we're satisfied that the purpose of
serving certificates and as part of the
planning form is to make sure that
everybody who needs to be aware of the
proposals is aware and has the
opportunity to comment and we're fully
satisfied that all parties have been
made aware and have indeed commented so
we satisfied that our duties have been
discharged insofar as that respect okay
so just to be absolutely clear one can
submit planning application on any piece
of land the ownership is purely to
notify whoever does own that land that
an application has gone in yes thank you
I think that's the key thing the whole
purpose of serving notices is to give
notice to landowners that a planning
application has gone in so even if
barely own a sliver of this land clearly
they know about the application of made
representations on it so that suffered
no prejudice counsel Dixon I was going
to ask that one but I have a photograph
of the the house the street
other than those which was actually seen
Stewart and especially given the format
and the the type of windows we've got
there the one that the design is
different it's got apex windows or
double windows cutting into the roofline
etc on the drawings etc and just
wondered if there are any similar in
that neighborhood just merely a small
matter thank you
yes of course the surrounding built form
clearly is a key consideration
for myself as a plenty officer and for
us you are correct that there are some
cutting 8x windows on the proposed
elevation or plans I have some
smattering of photos I don't think I
have every single house on the street
I'm afraid but we have made an
assessment that the elevations put
before us are commensurate with what the
surrounding built form in terms of the
type of built form put forward whether
it be a semi-detached or terrorists
properties largely comprising this
streets and but it's specifically on
that window point I haven't got a
definitive photo to show you of another
house which has that same apex I'm
afraid but I'm not aware of any is the
honest answer no but like I said design
what has happened consider clearly
infamous for the points of clarification
to go to the debate to start us off you
wanna go next yeah
so the obviously one of the overriding
concerns about the the ownership we it's
been made very clear that that is a
civil issue rather than a planning issue
I think we all know it's not a material
planning issue so that we can we can
disregard that at this point in terms of
the other issues that were raised I I
think that officers report is there's
perfectly detailed enough for us to make
a decision based on what we're saying I
don't agree that it's squeezing in too
much from what I can see from those
drawings from what we've seen online the
the shape and size of those buildings
are almost identical to those next door
on similar plot sizes so on that basis
I'm quite happy to go with the officers
recommendation of grant and make that
full of those thank you anybody else
want to speak ins yes counsel Jenni's
been purely on sort of if we're looking
at this affecting were being detrimental
to the street say like I can't see
I'm not allowed by so I'm happy to
second it thank you you've said over
everything else thinking I can see
absolutely no reason not to go for that
for this application it ticks all the
boxes as far as I can see and as we've
already established although it's
awkward for the Parish Council and it's
one maybe that will rumble on from the
Parish Council in terms of the land it's
not for this committee to decide so I'm
happy to go along with the officers
recommendation as well if nobody else
wants to speak on this application which
we go to the vote in proposed it's been
seconded there are no updates all those
in favor of granting you know miss Chen
thank you there for the committee
resolves to grant application reference
19 / 0 to 9 to 4 / ful we move to third
application for the evening
it's item 6 and it's found on page 29 of
your agendas the application reference
then is 19 / 0 to 4 3 3 / fu L is for
Deerfield farm me on hello Quentin and
it's for a new livestock building and
internal access tract presenting officer
Paul Thompson thank you
the this site is a an agricultural field
south and lower Quinton it's just
northeast of me on Hill which has a an
Iron Age hill fort on top the heart of
England way passes again to the the
south west of the site there are no
buildings or structures or trees on the
site it is just within the area
Cotswolds Arab outstanding natural
beauty which the boundary runs along the
north and the east of the site nearest
buildings are a dwelling house here to
the east
[Music]
which is a farmhouse and the building
itself will be in this northwestern
corner and fated to the site top is
towards me on hill and at the bottom is
towards the proposed site visible in the
in the bottom photograph is the access
which was constructed under a separate
planning permission
this shows the siting of the building
within the site with access Drive across
the field and this sighting has been
amended from the original submission
which would have been around here
there's additional planting shown which
we've secured or the recommended
condition and finally this is the
building itself fairly standard modern
agricultural building thank you Jeff
thank you to our speakers from the
Quinton Parish Council Paul Milliken
please welcome councillor Thank You mr.
chairman
so you also have three minutes if you'd
remember any questions at the end I'll
give you a one in ten seconds look it's
you let me highlight three concerns that
the Parish Council don't believe have
been properly addressed by the planning
officer the first is the impact of the
program proposed building and gravel
access road on the Cotswolds a lob this
new building and gravel access road sit
adjacent to within the ARB
and we'd be visible both from the
highway as well from the national
footpaths on the slopes of my own hill
question eight in the application asks
if a new or altered vehicle access is
proposed and the applicant answer's no
in fact the intention is to create a new
gravel access road 3.6 meters wide and
it's a significant length we estimate at
least 70 metres long this would impact
on the character of the LOB the second
concern is highway safety the entry to
the land parcel from the highway is part
tarmac but has largely been constructed
using dumped industrial waste
metals and light fittings this is mega
highway is littered with dangerous
debris hazardous to car users but also
cyclists and dog walkers this has led to
a loss of confidence amongst residents
in the applicants approach to managing
the health and safety traffic movements
turned from the site the third concern
is with the updated agricultural
justification statement the applicant
has four hundred breeding ewes and
intends to increase these numbers to
eight hundred once the new building is
constructed the consultant used by the
applicant elvenar states and I quote
based on the current flock size of four
hundred use the space requirement for
the use is well in excess of the floor
area of the proposed building on court
and adds that this is without
considering the space needed for the
Lambs the consultant notes also that
more building space would be required
for feedstuffs machinery etc in short
the applicant plans for his business
will require a much larger building than
currently proposed and this must mean
that this applications merely the
precursor to much larger building
proposals the committee will be aware in
fact that the original application was
for a much larger building which was
withdrawn recognizing the impact on the
LOB so again there's a lack of
confidence amongst residents in the
planning application noting that the
building proposed will be completely
inadequate to support the existing flock
let alone one twice the size the
committee should be aware that residents
have previously expressed concerns to
the parish council over animal welfare
on this site that prompted a visit from
Trading Standards thank you for the
parish
I think I got anything to like ice thank
you very much for attending the
applicant there
Simon recent Olli Pritchard please
welcome
so so which one mr. Pritchett hello mr.
e have you want to divide the time up
between I'm gonna start and then mr.
[ __ ] will finish shredding question
okay okay okay so over to you thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
my name is Simon Reis Madison reads
planning consultancy and I'm the agent
for the application firstly we welcome
the recommendation for approval from
your officers and free support they're
balanced and detail report the principle
of new farm buildings are accepted in
the adopted core strategy plan subject
to them being of an appropriate scale
and enter for the enterprise unnecessary
for the business we submitted an
agricultural appraisal from a qualified
specialist who advised that proposed
building is more than fully justified
for agricultural purposes
this view is backed up by the counselors
independent agricultural specialists who
also confirmed that the use of the
proposed building for landing and
storage is in their opinion appropriate
and necessary for the enterprise
we have amended the size scale and
massing of the proposed building as a
result of concerns from your officers
the building is similar in height to the
hay store on lower my own farm to the
northeast but smaller than the larger
buildings on that site
therefore the proposed building would be
no more visually prominent than the
existing built form in the surrounding
environment the building position has
also been amended to be sited in the
northwest corner of the site the ground
levels here are at the lowest with the
adjoining hedge and tree boundaries that
they're most mature and thickest that's
confirmed by your officer in their
committee report the building will be
largely screened from views from the
north and west insuring that they will
not detract from the use into the AO and
be planning conditions are recommended
to retain the existing hedges and trees
as well as provide a new robust planting
scheme we have worked closely with the
officers to amend the proposed scheme to
ensure that the building represents an
appropriate form of development within
the a and B we therefore respectfully
request that the Planning Committee
support the officers recommendation
hi my name is Oliver put you on the
applicant for
application in terms of background and
working on the current famine authority
however due to that divorce I've got to
leave the existing business a vast
amount of farm experience and this the
relocation has required me to make a
significant financial commitments I own
proximately 50 acres of land which is
split into two parcels this was recently
purchased for over half a million pound
with a new axis construction in addition
to this island into a new room with
another landowner for a further 480
acres of land as it stands I have four
hundred beaten use well this is it is my
aim to develop the largest 800 once in
holding and facilities are established
from looking to rear entry cars where
this cannot be done until either
building capable of accommodating them
along with the use this application is
not a speculative development and I'm
incredibly committed to running a
successful agricultural business having
missed a significant amount of money to
make this work I just hope the committee
you can see that my application is
genuine and that has significantly
reduced my proposal to accommodate the
concerns of your officers without this
building I do not have a sustainable I
business hope you can support my
application thank you very much for your
time perfect any questions the committee
councillor Perry thank you good evening
to you both I noticed in the parish
councils objection they made reference
to access to fresh water for the animal
welfare but they highlighted that they
haven't seen any evidence on this site
could you just highlight on that and you
know put an application in to seventh
rent water to put the mains in down the
road with I've got the contractor
already together
yeah that's all ball in hand thank you
good any other questions
[Music]
thank you one of the concerns that was
raised was regarding the the size
appropriateness of of the building for
the number of use that you're planning
to use on the site can you just
elaborate on that and their brokenness
of the proposed development please sorry
and yet will be everything they usually
lambda were staggered spirits and have
starting the end of December and they'll
go all the way till night so whilst a
Gramps uses so they've got a sufficient
amount of building space yeah okay right
courtesy counselor fit her in the room
so in that case points of clarification
yes counselor Jennings and councillor
Dixon just a couple of things saying I'm
presuming that animal welfare animal
welfare isn't a planning issue is it
correct okay and also have there been
any objections from highways thank you
very much okay Dixon thank German
question for the officers obviously I
think there's some fear locally of
potential change of use if this is
constructed and not actually required I
can remember times when agricultural
bonds if they were capable of being
converted could be converted into
residential is the nature of this
construction one which in future years
is currently as designed capable of
being converted or not so there's a
couple of ways we can address this the
building lies within the O and B so
they're sort of well publicized
permitted development rights for
converting
into dwellings would not apply in this
instance the other thing that we can
alight upon is its briefly mentioned in
the comments from the applicant we have
had this application scrutinized by our
own independent agricultural consultant
and they've confirmed from their point
of view it seems reasonable and
justified in terms of its size and the
proposals that the applicants coming
forward with in terms of farming the
land
yes cows Richards this probably won't
weigh heavily on my decision-making but
clearly we've had two aggregates
previously this clearly tied to
agricultural work why is this come as
nephew well rather than an act not is
there a particular reason
it's a livestock building that's within
400 metres of a dwelling house referred
as a protected building you know
legislation
did not know that thank you right no
other clarification debate counts Adam
could use again in relation to the fact
that this has had a history of being
changed in size for this application are
there restrictions reasonable
restrictions that were putting in to
restrict this in the future against
potential development of the site I
think his person to say that any further
extensions to this building would
require their own separate planning
permissions we would look at the
justification for any changes any
additional buildings and planning
applications that came forward would be
determined on their own merits with
respect to the planning policy and the
impact on the AO and B one other thing
which was Wells when presenting you
mentioned the application for the road
that was a separate application what
extent does that extend onto the site is
the is the main road that was raised as
concerned by the Parish Council included
in that in any way which that completely
separate the access that you can see in
the bottom picture here has planning
permission
separately it was granted permission in
2018 for memory and implementer yes
everything after that is part of this
application so if we've got conditions
recommended conditions to control that
yeah I've got Council Perry next I
thought we've gone on to debate debate
now okay okay
Thank You chair well first of all I
think I think we should be really
welcoming plans that are supporting the
growth of the UK food industry where we
have huge need for more food in the UK
it supports our business strands and the
economic development of the district and
I think it's particularly commendable
that someone is actually investing in
growing their own business we have all
the evidence supported by Kearns and our
independent agricultural advisor and I
think this is one that we should be
delighted to support the officers
recommendation and therefore I propose
that we go with the officers
recommendation and grant can't spare you
still pretty much work full hurdles
bound to say I think this is an
excellent application promoting business
at a time when we do need in this
country to be looking at
self-sufficiency food options I think
it's gonna be a really important thing
over the next video so I completely
concur with what you're going to say go
counts Adam then council Jennings
like the second those points and second
that we grant propose in a second
accounts Jenny's say the same sorry okay
right well we haven't proposed that we
have a second different cats out if
there's nothing else to be said on
that's just don't chose nothing I mean
to make that case all those in favor of
granting pre-show unanimous Jeremy thank
you okay so the committee results to
grant application reference 19/2 four
three three slash ful
right apology so that okay we go to our
last application 97 on page 39 the
agenda this application reference 19
slash 0 2 5 2 7 7 / fu out and it's for
39th and James presents how them is for
the direction of an existing carriage
and construction of a new dwelling
something officer port ops again over
here thank you sure this is a
residential part of salvan indicated by
the black dot and what we have is a
resubmission of an application that we
refused last year and it was submitted
in 2018 and the appeal was dismissed
we'll go into the reasons for that
during the presentation as you can see
it's a pair of semi-detached houses on a
corner plot with wide frontages facing
both milk present and James christen the
detached garage here and to the rear of
the of the application property and row
of terraces here to which the proposed
development responds here we can see the
existing property number 39 since James
present and the row terraces over here
and the garage here this is from the
window of my cart you can see the levels
here from sort of row level he does the
site does rise and sort of steps up from
the south to these terraces there and
this the elevations haven't changed
since the refused application one of our
reasons for refusal was the impact of
the the sighting and
development itself on the character in
the appearance of the area and the
inspector disagreed with that and
dismissed that reason for refusal saying
that it was in fact it wouldn't in fact
have an adverse effect on the character
in appearance of the area and it was
compliant with policy CS 9 CS 15 what
was upheld as a reason for a fuse or
basically the reason that the appeal was
dismissed was the lack of private garden
space it would have been overlooked
quite dramatically by the rear windows
of the existing house and that's been as
we see the inspector agreed with that
that has been resolved with a simple
expedient of inserting an ensuite
bathroom into the rear of the existing
dwelling with an obscure glazed window
and that will essentially cut off the
the view over the rear garden and reduce
any overlooking to a level equivalent to
that experienced by the existing
property and its neighbors as we can see
here this is a new site plan there have
been concerns raised around the parking
so forth County highways as you will
have seen from the updates you have this
week we've drawn their objection on the
grounds of the maneuvering at parking
maneuvering space is sufficient and
subject to the conditions that we've
recommended if the recommendation is to
grant thank you for right okay we have
only our water for this once
kasib Raj come on oh so you have five
minutes to speak if you'd remain seated
for any questions at the end that's very
good five minutes so basically I have
three major concerns on this one is such
on the street scene because it's not in
keeping with the character there the
area actually round there consists of I
were to say
such houses that X council how's it all
four blocks of four Terrace housings
that was an initial concern there is a
big concern that's a very very map that
pitch designs and dude just about it's
actually a very very small area at the
back probably about three meters square
if that realistically but my biggest
concerns actually on this parking and
I've actually done a bit of research in
line with national planning policy
framework and national parking
guidelines which says we should have a
two point four meter width for these
vehicles game crucially it should be
fairly easy to maneuver into there now
if you look at the parking space and
that is in front of the house the access
point to actually get two vehicles in
there's actually only three meters wide
does actually take measure it the other
day on that so I have a big concern that
you would struggle to actually get two
vehicles in there quite a lot of
maneuvering and you in my opinion they
are probably facing the wrong way
completely and the same applies to the
other side anything near the property
line towards the road you are looking at
a very awkward space actually back then
now I would suggest anything where a
small car would not get into those two
end spaces near near the pavement area
whatsoever indeed actually that's the
planning office or Mundi for the site
visit which we had to put it on for that
to actually Becky's car in and give you
an idea he has a small car and the
proposed parking area where the house
house actually is and the existing front
garden the actual turning point was the
area suggested for a small hatchback car
for the two cars to actually pull into I
don't think it's anywhere near
sufficient enough I think it needed to
be the opposite way round on that I
certainly have very big concerns
eighties over development on the
property it had a - had to store
extension part on it's in the late
nineteen eighties already originally it
was a three bedroom straight
four-bedroom house it could potentially
go back to eight four-bedroom house
because the end I don't think makes a
three-bedroom at the moment it's just
through where they opened up a doorway
to make into that so my concerns also
our long-term that's potentially if it
went back to being a four-bedroom house
two spaces would not be enough anyway
it's a four-bedroom house in line with
probably a reasonable assumption is at
least three of those four rooms would be
occupied with car drivers and as it's
very difficult to park on the street
there I think it could create a lot of
problems in the future we should take
that consideration I think generally the
design is not a very good it could have
been thought out better if you look at
the across the road if we can get the
picture coming for the house across the
road where they did have an extension
but we had didn't really cross the road
I think from what your angle pictures
know that's what cross road did have a
two slits how to built on it it was
actually in line with the existing two
semi-detached there who a slight gap
between a parking there a sensible
parking area in front whereby you're
coming straight onto the road that
access point if you try and actually
back into that make you would have to
cut the pavement the drop curve you
could not drop in and actually get into
the first the parking spaces needs to
head to whatsoever I think that's about
it right any questions for our walk
member yeah I think you said you had
three reasons objection a very nice -
yeah two of those ones the street scene
design yeah and the others the
maneuverability of the cars and the park
yeah
I do think the site would be
overdeveloped it'd be very wrapped on
that but God likes that I think at most
it probably a three meter by about three
meter proximally square back garden on
that obviously they're not because it's
for the cars okay so given that we've
been told that the heel inspector didn't
conclude that it was out keeping and
have character and tendency at 9 CS 15
why do you think what do you think we
should be using as playing reason to
depart from his decision I think the
first planning weeks and obviously I
think I thought you didn't get the car
park no nothing so reasonable I'm sorry
I'm thinking specifically of the designs
is yes but design is I don't actually
don't think the property is quite
located in the right places quite simple
the biggest issue I think there if
you've got a property where you've got
the property next doors has a sizable
extension to the side it's in keeping
with where the four Terrace housings are
and the semi-detached look I think that
would look very much out of place being
set back because there is no her
properties on that street they're
actually set back that substantial
amount the house across the road which
was built in addition I think you've
answered my question for that yeah and
in terms of the parking and dimensions
and layout what have you with we're told
that this wasn't raises a specific
objection in the previous why I see it
actually raise its own acts why put my
previous objection the previous
application part one was actually one of
them and that's how I state it was my
previous objections actually stood at
that point and I could bring this up
with the funding officer on Monday and
points out actually I did objector that
originally okay I'll get into clarify
that thing yeah points questions from
there Katie I just want to clarify one
more thing so in terms of the street
scene is unless I'm missing things
purely the fact that this is a to tap a
single detached why don't you think is
is out of keeping with
I think so I think he pursed I think
just one less desiring to just them okay
that's fine thank you if there are no
other questions to be a committee
counsel thank you very much thank you
right points clarification we can I just
start I just want to Jets the garden
space is it 3x3 okay we'll come back
right can I just ask the officers for
clarification on the parking widths that
were highlighted by councillor Bromwich
and in an Ave in accordance with our
parking standards I thought the issue
raised by counts lebra Mitch if I
understood him correctly was that the
access onto the site was too narrow and
I would draw members attention to the
condition proposed which seeks for the
widening of that access it was council
Bromwich made reference to the fact that
he felt the maneuverability of the cars
getting into the parking space and
highlighted a width of 2.4 meters and
just to be clear so that the spaces are
do meet the dimensions with the SPD
characters I was not asked about the the
car parking as well dimensions is you've
clearly laid out with in your report fit
our requirements with a manoeuvrability
does it do we have specific requirements
in terms of wits and gaps and all that
sort of stuff that it fits the manual
for streets specifies an aisle width of
7 meters which it does comply with in
the the highways engineer confirms it
complies okay thank you
final question was on the garden space
yes it exceeds 50 square meters that is
required in those stands okay so there's
more than with okay go do you have an
aerial view of the google map view just
so I can get full impression of the
layout of the property of the existing
okay yeah I can wait I can do on my own
thing but I didn't want to be rude and
not everyone else it
I cancelled it whilst David's just
preparing that is it possible to fully
understand the ensuite was that this
this potential design or was it the one
that's existing there please
that's the existing dwelling cancer
yeah
I think I might've just found the answer
I'm assuming that the proposed new house
doesn't have any windows in its side
elevation occasions we go to the debate
council Jennings where the rest the
table their picture of satisfied the
pealed inspectors objections and I'm
sort of saying if we refuse this they'll
go to appeal them and win and we're
gonna have cost implications I'm
presuming ok that's Richard thank you
and so working through the three reasons
of objection that we've heard from our
ward member the first of which i think
is satisfied by our appeal
inspector decision I didn't hear
anything from him or I haven't heard
anything within our report that suggests
that we should depart from that decision
so I think that from that perspective
cs9 gs-15 satisfies in terms of the
maneuverability layout and car parking
we've heard from our offices and again
it is very clearly detailed within our
report that this does satisfy their
requirements and it's been adjusted to
fit those requirements indeed we have
world highways who have in our update
sheet she was drawn there objection
I did have initial concerns I must say
before I saw that update sheet but
having had that withdrawn I don't think
we can pin ourselves on that the final
one about the over there and the
overdevelopment it's one of the reasons
why I wanted to bring up that site so we
could have a look at it when we look at
the photos clearly there's a garage
there and we don't get to see the full
extent a little and and get a feeling
understanding of what the full extent of
the land is with that in situ when we
look at it from a bird's eye view
knowing that that's going actually we
get a better feeling for it and actually
having done that I'm entirely satisfied
that this does fit on
it is not in there for an over
development and I can see no reason
therefore to depart from the decision
that's been made by our case offices so
I will be proposing that we do go along
with our offices recommendation to grant
thank you yes a pair of you indicated
Thank You chair I'd like to support the
councillor Richards comments which
mirror my own
we have no material planning reasons to
refuse this application particularly in
light of the appeal and therefore I'm
happy to second the proposal debunked
thank you anybody else wanted to speak
on the base at this point I think it's
all been said really I think you every
point counts right on them just one no I
can't see any material planning reasons
to refuse it but I did visit the site to
have a look and get an idea of the
proportion that I think that the
concerns raised over the manoeuvrability
and fitting the qartheen isn't
completely unfounded and I don't think I
can support it on that basis and so I
think I'll be abstaining on it but I
think that's definitely something we
should consider when when looking at
this and similar application of the
future so that's that's my position on
this okay do we have a proposal and it's
been seconded that we grant should be
able to vote all those in favor please
show a sixth chairman those against and
abstentions abstain hypertension's Baker
thank you okay the committee there full
results - grant application reference 19
/ 0 to 5 7 7 / ful that I think is our
last application for the evening we have
no urgent business the meeting is closed
thank you I just